[Music]
hey rob matt from detroit
just wondering if
thinking back to movies made before you
were born
what do you think would be the one movie
and one part
you would have loved to have done
before your birth that you didn't have a
chance to
thanks thanks matt thanks for calling
well it would immediately pop to my mind
and it's it wasn't before i was born
technically because i believe the movie
came out in 1969
would be butch casting the sundance kit
um it i i
look there are other great movies
obviously
i i would that would have been but i
would have i would love to play butch
cassidy
i mean i would love to do a modern day
butch cassidy i'd love to go back in
time and be
in the what is it what in the metaverse
not the metaverse what are they calling
it the uh the in the in the multiverse
3.0 whatever it is
hopefully they can
use my avatar and put me in
butch cassidy someday and you can see
what that would be like but the other
part of it is i would have loved to have
been around in the era
of the traditional romantic leading man
screwball comedies
like his girl friday
bringing up baby
front page
the sort of
howard hawks fast talking
um movies i i would have loved those and
i think those would have been in my
wheelhouse um and those are great ones
philadelphia story
um cary grant jimmy stewart if you
haven't seen those movies that you
should they're great um and definitely
we're not making anything remotely like
those anymore
really great question i could go on and
on with this one um
but uh thanks for calling and keep
listening
you